left-wing media seeds over success of
anti-child trafficking films sound of
Freedom the movie tells the story of Tim
Ballard all of you know it I'm a big fan
of the film it was it was absolutely
fantastic I recommend that you check it
out but oh boy
reports from left-wing news sites
Jezebel and the guardian have tried to
discredit the hit release sound of
Freedom linking it with conspiracy
theories
do we have the tweet from Jack was over
here let me show you this one
he says in plain sight
Rolling Stone says sound of Freedom the
Q Anon tinged Thriller about child
trafficking is designed to appeal to the
conscience of a conspiracy adult Boomer
and then there's from Rolling Stone
thanks to a major marketing mistake the
award-winning French movie cuties was
accused of sexualizing young girls it's
actually a sensitive portrait of growing
pains it deserves to be seen
that's who these people are
the groomers
yeah sound of freedom is doing really
really well and of course we're seeing
leftists get absolutely upset about it
but this is good news across the board
because it shows that we are winning on
cultural grounds we're winning on uh on
on in the Arts it's not about
conservatives winning it's about people
pushing back against the creepy woke
cult establishment garbage
um winning as a whole or just getting a
win winning as a whole
I just watched this if you look across
the board right
you can argue that the left holds let's
say you have you have a country and
there's like 12 jurisdict 12
battlefronts 12 counties or
jurisdictions and the right only
controls six of them they're winning
that fight gaining ground and spreading
even if the left holds more institutions
they are losing control of them I fair
and I didn't want to sound too negative
right there I was just curious of what
you were talking about
um Target Starbucks sound of freedom for
sure for sure no no you're I mean we're
definitely on the offensive move right
now when it comes to people that just
are sick and tired of the like woke
Elite that dominates all these
institutions all of that
um I do have to admit I haven't seen the
movie yet well it just came out yeah I
am gonna watch it and I do know is it
not based on a true story true story The
it's based on true story there's some
embellishments in it FBI am I getting
this uh Homeland Security Homeland
Security uh you might have been ice I'm
not sure in X right so he got out of it
and then quit because they he wanted to
save the kids and he couldn't you know
in working for the government right so
based on a true story and that appeals
to Q Anon conspiracy theorists I mean
that's they just thought of that and
they said okay this is what we can do to
get the general population away from
this movie even though it's performing
really really well I mean it beat out
Indiana Jones on its opening day right
yeah Indiana Jones had opened over the
weekend and then it was a Tuesday that
this movie came out but it beated on
that Tuesday so it made like 10.8
million where Indiana Jones made like
10.7 or something like that still India
made 80 million over the weekend right
right that's still I mean it's still
doing fantastic obviously uh but that's
um and so that's I I I think that they
really just wanted people to kind of not
dig into that story and that's not the
first time I've seen them bring up Q
Anon Rolling Stone yeah they weren't the
first people to to repeat that narrative
it's a Q on movie yeah I've seen it all
over Twitter like a bunch of people are
talking about making some kind of
connection to Q Anon um I don't think
that the average person like I don't
think Q Anon resonates with the average
person the people that have about 15
minutes to watch the news a day you know
20 minutes or whatever they grab like
they watch a little bit in the morning a
little bit in the evening when they're
doing their life
um I don't think Q Anon I think they
hear that and it's in one year yeah it
was only because of outlets like this
that I knew what Q Anon was because I
heard it thrown around by people
tweeting stuff like that I'm like what
is this yeah but Panic um was anyone
talking about why Disney held on to this
movie for would they have the rights for
like five years I believe it was already
made five years ago for a sound of
Freedom yeah it was made five years ago
really yeah and uh well I can make some
assumptions as to why it couldn't get
released let's hear it because there are
groomers in Hollywood
and pedophiles in Hollywood and you make
a movie about ending child trafficking
and you'll end up with some Hollywood
executive being like Oh Haram if I say
but what about what I want to do when I
fly down there right
so um let's just say based on what we
know from uh some individuals who
produce documentaries about Hollywood's
the trafficking the abuse hey let's talk
about um Elliot page who claims to have
been uh assaulted you know uh in in this
industry
yeah they made a movie about child
trafficking being bad and wanting to end
it and then the big networks were like
the big studios were like uh oh we
shouldn't let people see this I'm gonna
go ahead and make an assumption as to
why that is yeah I was just watching RFK
Juniors uh interview with Lex Friedman
on Lex's Channel on YouTube and I saw
about half of it but at one point RFK
Junior was talking about project mocking
operation Mockingbird the CIA taking
control of the media in like the 60s and
70s then they were ordered I think it
was a church commission where they're
like you got to stop and they're like
okay but RFK was like I don't think they
really ever stopped and he was naming
Outlets that have been co-opted by the
CIA or that are assets Daily Beast was
the first one then he mentioned Rolling
Stone magazine yeah right away and then
I see Rolling Stones the one that's
trashing this ever since the 2012 ndaa
was signed the uh what is it the Smith
munt modernization Act uh was in the
ndaa and that made it legal for the
federal government to propagandize the
American people in nineteen after World
War II the smithmont ACT said that the
American population cannot be
propagandized by the federal government
and it was in response to what they had
learned that the the Nazis and the
Soviets had done before leading up to
and during World War World War II and
the federal government you know the
people were like look the federal
government shouldn't be making decisions
about what the people think right the
people the government should be a
reflection of the population not the
population or reflection of what the
government wants and that's borne out in
the way that governments have treated
their populations when their population
doesn't act the way the government wants
them or it doesn't behave the way they
want them to
um so that that the the Smith
modernization Act was in 2011 and ever
since like the narrative coming out of
the mainstream media has been the exact
narrative that the Democrats want you
had all of the time that Barack Obama
was the president basically setting up
this this app apparatus and then when
Donald Trump was elected the Deep the
Deep State the entrenched bureaucracy it
was already in place already prepared to
discredit anyone that would try to pull
back the power from the federal
government and obviously that's the you
know the conservatives if one of the
parties is going to make the government
smaller it is not going to be the
Democrats I'm not trying to convince
people that the Republicans are going to
be good or they're going to be you know
small government or random not that's
not the argument that I'm making but the
Govern the federal government has been
propagandizing the American people in
conjunction with rolling stone team
Vogue Cosmopolitan and again this is
something that I brought up on this on
the the show before you will get the
same type of uh stories in Cosmopolitan
in GQ in Teen Vogue in Good Housekeeping
and in probably in maybe not field in
stream but I wouldn't be all that
surprised because there is no
significant difference in opinion
because the narrative from almost all
the mainstream is the narrative that the
federal government wants to be presented
to the American people
that's the way that is that's the way
that I see it now Amen brother Teen
Vogue praising marks yeah I love it
that's hilarious did that actually that
actually happened that actually happened
what did they say they were talking
about was it like a month ago right no
that was a long time ago okay okay yeah
like Marx was misunderstood or something
like that it was actually really really
funny it's got it's kind of hairy you
know you know but funny at the same time
Teen Vogue it's like young women getting
fashion advice and information on uh
supporting the proletarian overthrowing
the uh the the elites and the is this is
this from 2018 Karl Marx the famed
philosopher and author of the Communist
manifest can you imagine years old can
you imagine calling like gerbils a famed
philosopher like honestly like Marx is
responsible for millions and millions
and dozens of millions his ideas have
were responsible for dozens of millions
of deaths in in the in the 20th century
at least the word Infamous they should
have said the infamous philosopher no
because they're surprised
Infamous is not enough Infamous is not
enough for me he's a terrible guy too
overweight you guys are talking about it
I almost chimed in because yeah there's
a lot of like yeah if he misses how you
describe like Al Capone not somebody's
whose you know ideology was the reason
for dozens of millions of deaths tens of
millions of deaths all around the world
yeah and it was just the idea that
everyone deserves a little bit it was
the IDE it was the idea that man can be
perfected because you cannot have a
utopian society where everybody works
and puts in and produces equally and
gets out right from the government
equally what so what the plan was was to
re make man into new socialist man that
could be considered a socialist man that
is a social being it was a very popular
idea in the late late part of the uh uh
18th century I think it was 19th century
um yeah but it was it was Nichi was
talking about it too because he had like
uber Mensch yeah the Uber mentioned the
over man uh Thus Spoke zarathusion is
the book
um but the idea was that
you know Darwin had had put out his his
uh Origin of Species and and people were
understanding learning about Evolution
and starting to understand that and the
idea was we had conquered religion man
had conquered religion and man now could
understand science and we could use
science to remake man into the new man
that's the modern man that doesn't need
all the old uh you know the the old old
ways and the old religions and stuff and
it it just ends up with people dying and
mass because you can't make people not
people it sounds like you're talking
about transhumanism it well I mean it
transhumanism for that yeah it is an
extension of the same type of ideas but
the point of of of sort the point of
socialism is to have a socialist world
like a communist world where nobody as
has has anything more than someone else
so the abolishment of class right see
the abolishment of property so that way
no one has more than someone one else
and everyone has e has equal things but
the problem is people have different
capabilities people are born with
different attributes people are taller
people are slower people are faster
people are the the they're infinitely
different so to think that people are
going to be able to put in and take out
equally is is ridiculous so the effort
to make people equal the only thing you
can do is take from the people that
succeed hold people down because if
you've got a person that's incapable of
doing something right just
well that's incapable you can never make
them capable you have to find the people
that are capable and take and take away
their ability easiest way to explain it
is you can't make the grass grow but you
can't mow the lawn yep thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time